joining me now is victor davis hanson
hoover institution senior fellow
victor uh you called what's happening
right now
the great awokening so what is the
current
this racializing of america going to
lead to
what will it make america look like and
seem like over the next few years
i don't think anybody knows but it's
based on a lot of dubious assumptions
laura
one is that merit never was really
important it was just a construct
so if you want half of the new pilot
training
candidates at united based on race it
won't matter
or if you're going to arbitrarily
restrict half the white population that
gets into harvard or yale
it didn't matter or if you're going to
lower bar standards they were too high
anyway and that's an experiment we'll
see what happens
i'm very dubious and then there's
another and that is that these ceos mr
bassinet take one example of delta that
they're always going to have the power
to navigate around their own ideology
it's never going to come back to devour
or cannibalize the architects
their kids will always get on harvard
they'll always be ceos
they can always use your their money and
influence to
dictate to others but it will never come
to them but history says it always comes
to them
that's what the bolsheviks told us
they're in the target too but they think
their money and their privilege will
protect them they think that 70
of the population who wants borders
secure who wants a voter id who
supports uh oil and gas exploration and
doesn't want race to
adjudicate admissions and hiring that
they're quiet they're sober they're
passive
they'll never rise up the 30 percent who
are woke and they control silicon valley
and
entertainment and wall street and the
corporation they're what they have to be
afraid of yeah i don't think that
that's necessarily right either i want
to i want to i don't want to
leave yeah i want to take everyone back
to that call
because we got to ground people and what
just happened over the weekend
so i guess now it was about 120
corporations and leaders were on this
big zoom call now this guy sonnenfeld
this yale professor who organized it
said that the strong attendance on the
call was a statement of defiance
against republican pushback of corporate
criticism
we had the top brass of american
airlines united airlines and delta
if they're going to boycott airlines
they better have their own
jet he said talk about
elitists not everyone can be like john
kerry uh
on the private jet or you know any of
the other big goldman sachs folks who
probably
think this is all great
yeah i don't think they make very good
representatives of the woke movement and
they shouldn't lecture people on
equity and inclusion and diversity
because that's what they're doing
if you're a ceo at delta and you make 17
million dollars a year that works out to
about
65 000 a day for each working day i
don't think anybody wants to take you
very seriously about how
committed you are to equity because you
could do a lot in the
concrete rather than just the abstract
so people are getting really tired
of being lectured by these groups and
you know they're going to find out
that we're going to start to ask them
exactly what are the percentages
of race and gender in your own corporate
boardroom and your own
children going to prep schools and ivy
league because so far
it's always been the consequences of our
theories were going to fall on
irene irredeemable and you know donnie
deplorable but never us or the poor
asians or
luck hapless but never us and that's
going to happen to them and we'll see
what they say but
i don't take anything seriously as ceo
says or any of these people yeah and
they've really eroded have you noticed
they've revoted conservative
support for corporation the military and
uh
why are we funding any of this like we
got to go we got to go but
the fact that we give more incentives
for this behavior
is obscene victor you hit the nail on
the head thank you so much